hey everybody if you just joined us over
here we'll get started in just a second
we're waiting for everybody to come
over
I'm just making sure it's pushing
everybody over from the from the demo
room if you just jumped over here will
be here in just a second just confirming
it's pushing us
over Moment of
Truth okay I think it did I give people
a second here to continue jumping
in
okay Ryan on your end can you see people
jumping over into the Q&A room I think
it looks like there's 52 of us
here we can probably get
started okay actually can't see the
number but we're good thank you for the
the uh confirmation in the chat that it
successfully worked and let me pull
Simon over
here with us as well thank you so much
Simon for the awesome demo and thank you
all for joining us over here yeah thank
you all for joining us over here for the
Q&A too and spending time with us this
Wednesday as a reminder if you do want
to ask any questions
anonymously you can use the link that
I've been sharing in the previous chat
but I'll share it again right here but
you can also just ask questions in the
YouTube chat here
too um but I I usually save this for the
very end of our presentations but I
thought it may be worth saying at the
beginning too I know Simon showed he was
working from workbench and connect so if
anybody's ever interested in doing a
trial of workbench or connect shown
today um you can use this link to book a
call with our team and receive an
evaluation environment they love to chat
more with you about your use case so I
just want to make sure
I didn't forget to share that there so a
lot of
times know companies might already be
using our tools so if you just want more
information on how to connect with
others too within your own company how
we're supporting your company you can
also let me know here at this short link
it's just POS
os.it connect us um I was doing this
through my LinkedIn and through email
before so I figured it' just be good to
have one place there but thanks again
for for joining us um I'd love to just
start with some intros here of all of us
in the room I know Simon you already
introduced yourself but maybe for the
Q&A as well but a quick fun fact Ryan
and Simon sometimes get mixed up and now
I can see
why Simon do you want to introduce
yourself first yeah sure thing um my
name is Simon I work on the Tidy model
team at posit working on open- Source
software for machine
learning Ryan want toer yourself yeah um
I'm also Simon no I'm just kidding I'm
Ryan I'm a data science adviser here at
posit uh so I work really closely with
all of our posit customers and
non-customers just spreading the good
word about our open source tools and our
professional tools and so we've been
we've been hosting these demos now for
quite some time uh and um there was a
pretty impressive attendance today which
was really awesome to see but um yeah
that's
me and I'm Rachel Dempsey I lead our
customer marketing here at posit and I
host quite a few of our community events
like these end to end workflows and the
data science hangout as well so so happy
to see y all here and see all some of
these great questions coming in want to
give a thank you to you Ryan as well for
leading some of the uh past sessions too
it looks like we have a new record to
beat with the number of people joining
this one
though um okay so let's jump into the
Q&A let's see so one
of the questions that came in a bit
earlier on YouTube
was does tidy model have a large
language model equivalent with
fine-tuning a pre-trained model for
example also how does one set up GPU
support this is a great question um and
this is one we get a lot so tidy models
is focused on predictive modeling for
tabular data um and so large language
models are out of the scope of Tidy
models um but there has been quite a bit
of effort about um integrating large
language models generally into the the
IDE experience in our
studio um for GPU support though tidy
models is compatible with any parallel
backend that you can register
with for each uh which is a package in R
so there's there's all sorts of
different Frameworks that you can use to
uh connect to the computational
resources you have um and tidy models
from there will handle all the the
interfacing with
course great thank you um I forgot I can
just pull these over from YouTube here
so let me show one that's coming in now
the question was our markdown is not
Suited for this similar to Jupiter
notebook using armit is there any tool
that you might recommend to
me so I think this might
be okay yeah there is
a comment just before this about how uh
Mustafa instructs undergraduate students
and so um they went to share a notebook
with the students that they can um check
out coding
and um see some like narrative
in in that notebook while they're
teaching so sorry I didn't realize it
was two-part question so I showed the
first part now yeah let me read again
okay as teaching data science for
marketing analytics using arm posit for
undergrad students I want to have a
notebook where we write code and write
text in it and share with the
students
might have lost Rachel
there all as well I think we can
uh okay we lost you for a second there
Rachel
but I think we got the question all good
yeah okay well I hear this uh for sure I
think the the idea here is like can we
pass along some sort of notebook to
students where they can actually
interface with code inside of the
notebook while they're um learning
one option for this that um I have
really enjoyed over the years is the
learn r package so you can uh put
together tutorials where P students can
actually run code um inside of an R
session uh from their browser and uh or
on a a hosted server uh and then you can
intersperse your explanation and stuff
through there um also if you were
working in an environment um like
um uh a posit team session where you can
just have students pull the r mark down
into their own IDE session in that
instance as well our markdown could do
the trick or Cordo would do the same
thing great thank you seems like a
really fun time for my Wi-Fi to go out
so
hopefully okay um another question was
are there other R alternatives to m m
mops other than vver and pin and
tidy I'll give a go at this I'd also be
interested to hear y'all's perspectives
on this um I think there was there was
really a dir of options in R for
deployment before V came around um and I
would say uh to my knowledge it's really
like the complete solution to that
problem that I'm aware
of yeah and some pretty much nailed it
but there really was I mean there was
lots of
mlops uh tools within the python
ecosystem but there wasn't really one
that stood out in the r world like you
can certainly kind of build your own you
know way to monitor models and deploy
models but there wasn't one a single
tool for that and so that was really the
driving force behind vver um so there
are probably ways you can you know hom
grow some solutions here but really the
reason why V was created is to make that
one solution for
mlops so I I see there are few related
to um cicd and so one that came in on
slido from Lorenzo was how about
managing deployments via gitlab cicd or
GitHub actions or some other cicd
tool and maybe good to even just like
give an explanation for anyone who
doesn't know what cicd is what that
stands for as
well yeah so I can talk a little bit
about that and then Simon you can
certainly round out any edges here but
the cicd is the continuous integration
continuous deployment kind of almost
like set it and forget it kind of method
for either deploying products or
monitoring products so for posit
tools and speaking to the point of like
taking a model or something that you've
created in R Python and deploying it to
say connect so that it lives there it
can be shared and consumed by people um
there are ways that you can integrate
with things like GitHub actions to
constantly have that deployment process
automated via some kind of trigger for
example like maybe there's um you know
an update to a repository or something
that can trigger that cicd pipeline to
automatically deploy your model your
updated model so that's one way to do it
with GitHub actions there's also within
posit connect there's a feature for job
scheduling so if you wanted to for
example every morning at 7 a.m. rerun
your model to pull in the latest data
and retrain that model and deploy that
that pinned V model you can certainly do
that with posit connect as well so those
are kind of the two methods that I would
speak to right
now yeah I would say hit the nail in the
head I was going to go try and grab that
link to the part about Job scheduling
but that was too much multitasking so if
anybody wants to put it into the chat
feel free
um one other question
was how performant or fast is tidy
models compared to other Frameworks in
our so tidy models uh doesn't implement
the algorithms used to train the models
ourselves we make use of um existing
packages in R to make that happen and
then we have a layer on top that sort of
standardizes the way that you interface
with those
models um earlier this year we spent a
good amount of time making sure that the
layer on top of those existing R
packages that we've written is as
performant as possible so once you're
training
um more complex models or you're working
with uh data that most people will see
in an applied context that overhead is
basically negligible so your your
modeling pipeline is as fast as is other
otherwise possible uh in R we
also have a few tricks up our sleeves to
um reduce the amount of models that you
actually need to train to still be able
to evaluate many models at once and uh
we set up uh we try to make it very easy
to accidentally do the most performant
um approach to a modeling problem that
uh somebody might be tackling
thank you I see Carlos asked a question
over on YouTube thanks Simon for the
presentation regarding the model
monitoring I saw an example in vierse
page but is there something developed to
automatically check
that I think uh Ryan's answer to the
question about continuous integration
might speak to this okay A bit um and
V's page will have some resources about
how to uh how to connect to different
continuous integration
options okay thank
you another question that I saw over
on YouTube is wondering if you could
talk a little bit about the process and
how much of it can oh I guess this is
also cicd can also be obtained sounds
like we need another session on this
topic
too yeah right okay um but if there's
anything you want to add here Ryan it
looks like you were about to say
something um I'll have to go back to
some of our previous um posit team
workflow videos but I'm pretty sure at
least one of them we've highlighted some
of that job scheduling capabilities
within posit connect um and so we'll
drop the link here to our previous
recording so you can always go back to
those and check out that feature but uh
like Rachel mentioned this sounds like
it might be a a really nice Topic in the
future maybe like a a part two to this
session yeah and that's actually a good
reminder to say like if there are things
you want to learn about or curious about
feel free to post those in the chat
right now as well so we can gather that
information this was a just like a fun
question I wanted to ask you both but
what's oh I didn't I have a typo here
what's your favorite ml model you
interact with
let let me go first because my my
knowledge of modeling is not to the
extent of Simon but um during our posit
conference uh I was actually fortunate
to host a workshop um where we actually
took in real data from some restaurants
around the Chicago area and we built a
model uh and that was my first kind of I
would say my first but my real indepth
um usage of an XG boost model um which I
know is a very very popular uh you know
model so that was so that's now my
current
favorite I love to hear it yeah and my
my answer is super similar um X boost is
one option for an engine that you can
use to fit a boosted tree model with
tidy models
um another engine that we implemented
maybe a year or two ago um is called
light GBM it's another framework for uh
boosted trees that is available in R and
um
the thing that I really like about it it
very similar to XG boost um it's quite
tunable you can find the right
configuration for it pretty easily that
will result in a performant model and
light GBM is um really similar in that
way but it
also um the time that it takes to fit
the model scales with the inputs
somewhat differently than ex boost and
so in a lot of situations you can uh
achieve similar performance
with quicker fit
time um I thank you for those answers
what I actually was just curious about
is like do you have a favorite machine
learn learning model you come across
like in your daily life that is like
very fun to you like Netflix
recommendations uh I was thinking the
one I probably use the most is on Amazon
when it's recommending what else I
should be buying like the Subscribe and
save it's like you should probably also
subscribe for
this I would I think this was one of the
examples I called out in the talk but I
very much appreciate goofing around on
Zillow and just looking at like uh
apartments and houses in the in the city
and the estimates that are attached to
those come from a machine learning
model yeah I'm trying to think of one
here I guess maybe with just random
social media where you get some
advertisements about something that
you're like I guess I really did need
this because machine learning tells me
and you end up buying some random stuff
on Instagram or something I've done that
a couple times I try and fight it for so
long I'm like I don't want to give in
but they think I need this and then
eventually I I will get
it um another question from YouTube was
if I deploy a model to connect what is
the best practice to bring this into a
shiny app do you schedule the model to
update and Export the data to an RDS in
Connect want me you take that one
Simon yeah sure yeah so um when you have
a a model um specifically deployed with
vver you I would say the best way and
what V makes really easy is that it can
take your model and serve it as an API
um and that API can be either a plumber
API it can be a fast API and then once
it's serving as an API to have your
shiny application speak to the API is
insanely easy um and so that would be
our recommendation mostly because that's
what V kind of suggests it gives you the
tools to actually easily create that the
API so and even if you've never created
an API before uh check it out like go to
the the the V GitHub pages and they have
some examples on how to create a very
simple API because if you're like me
when I started kind of Dipping my toes
into the API world I thought I was going
to be weighing over my head because it's
like apis that's super scary um but it's
not um V makes it insanely easy and then
you can take that API you can host it on
connect and it will continue to run
there forever so it's always ready to be
interacted
with yeah it's a great
answer awesome I really liked um your
explanation of an API Ryan in one of the
workflow demos that you gave and there's
a blog post that goes along with it so
I'm going to share that in the chat here
too um but another question that came
over on slido was how could I use tidy
models to retrain a model after getting
new data in order to update
it so
part of this question I think is uh
comes back to the
cicd um I
think so if uh you're getting new data
on a
continuous basis and you want to run the
whole modeling pipeline uh all the way
through then you can uh use the same
script that you used to fit the model in
the first place and um connect it
through continuous integration in the in
the same way like we discussed before
but I think another part of the question
is like is there a way to interface with
the um model updating methods that some
modeling engines have an R so the idea
here is um if I've trained a model on a
million observations I get 100,000 more
do I have to go back and like run the
algorithm on all of those million and
100,000 observations or is there some
way to incorporate the information from
those 100,000 into to the
original um only a subset of engines in
tidy models will be able to do that that
just depends on um what
the the model supports um but if that's
available through the modeling engine
then you can interface with it in tidy
models as
well awesome thank you I see we have
time for a few more questions here and I
realized I missed one a bit earlier but
it was curious how to achieve linear
regression and logistic regression using
tidy models I want to do time series
analysis yeah so in the demo of the
slides where I was showing like what the
Tidy models code would look like and
then what the code would look like with
a bunch of different engines um that uh
code is what we would use to fit a
linear regression in tidy models and the
code looks super similar to do the same
for logistic regression so you can read
more about what models are available in
tidy models at the parsnip website uh
that's pars snip. tidy mods.org
for time series analysis there's a bit
more to this question um I spoke a
little bit to how tidy models is
extensible any developer can add on to
tidy models we try to make it really
straightforward to incorporate
um uh meth methods that further the the
ecosystem without us having to kind of
uh give it a thumbs up one of the
uh there's like an ecosystem of packages
that was developed by somebody external
to our team it's called Model time and
uh model time again is it's from a user
uh in the community and uh there's all
sorts of options to working with time
series models using tidy models through
that package that's the model time
package from business
science great thank you I'm copying that
one over into the chat
too there we
go um a question I wanted to ask a bit
earlier is I saw on the
previous uh YouTube room that we were in
somebody said they're using tidy models
for their dissertation and um I'm
curious like how does it feel for you
hearing things like
that it's so so cool uh it's really hard
to put into words how uh how exciting to
hear like the different applications
that people bring tidy models in for
um yeah I think that's like one of the
best parts of my job is like hearing
about the kinds of problems that people
are trying to solve uh being able to
poke around with their data myself and
uh learn a little bit about how people
are using what we work
on definitely okay maybe two more
questions so one here
is could you remind us what the package
is that has the Tidy models default
tuning parameter recommendations I can't
remember if it's an addin or if it's an
actual
package so um the package that
contains the information that tells the
rest of Tidy models how to tune
parameters that package is called
dials uh and you can learn about it at
dials. tidy mods.org so that package
contains information about tuning
parameters and anywhere else in the Tidy
models if you say I want to tune the
number of trees Teddy models will ask
dials okay what do we know about the
number of trees as a tuning parameter uh
and what option should we try out to um
get that tuning parameter right and then
uh dials will tell tidy models what
values to try out um and you can add all
sorts of custom configurations to how di
dials will provide those
recommendations great thank you it's
funny how when I hear these package
names now I like picture the hex
stickers for
them we tend to name packages in a
pretty silly way keep it
light okay maybe this will be our last
question and if there's some that I miss
I'll go through and try and collect
those and um maybe send them over to um
Simon if that's okay but uh last
question what's coming up soon in tidy
models and what are you most excited
about
we have two sort of big efforts that the
team has been Focus focusing on um
throughout this year and both of them
are very close to to being released
which I'm super excited about uh one of
them is uh better tooling for survival
analysis so um the censored package and
tidy models has a lot of the
um the bread and butter uh code for how
all that will happen uh and we're
working on integrating that with the
rest of the ecosystem um and so I think
in the coming months hopefully by the
new year we'll have um lots of uh
documentation and some release notes
about how that came
together uh the other thing that um I've
personally been spending a lot of time
on and um this is coming about after the
we we brought together a reading group
within pit about model fairness so uh if
a model is
predicting um outcomes that are somehow
related to people we want to make sure
that we understand the ways that um a
model might predict values differently
for different
subpopulations um and there's all sorts
of tooling out there for um learning
about how models uh understand
information about um
subpopulations and uh we've been putting
together some functionality so that
people can interface with those methods
using tidy
models awesome well thank you so much
Simon for the amazing demo today and
staying on here to answer all of our
questions and H thank you Ryan too for
jumping in here to help with the Q&A as
well I uh I appreciate all the amazing
questions in the chat as well and again
I'm sorry if anything happened to go
unanswered I'm going to go try and grab
all those questions and I'll share them
with Simon as well um but I did put up
on the screen if you're interested in
joining future sessions maybe this was
your first one thank you for joining us
um you can add them to your calendar
using the short link on the screen pos.
itte demo and we have these the last
Wednesday day of every month with a new
data science
workflow um but if you'd also like to
spend more time with us this week you
can join us tomorrow at the data science
hangout and Julia Sil from posit will be
joining us as our featured leader and so
you can just look up pait data science
Hangout to find out more info about that
um and I'll share it here in the chat
too lots of fun things going on and
again if you are just curious now after
watching this if your team does already
use our tools or you want to connect and
chat with us you can also um just let me
know using this short link I shared in
the chat too just POS
os.it connect
us um also feel free to connect on
LinkedIn too it's so nice to see so many
of you here today thank you so much for
joining us
thanks everybody bye everybody have a
good one